um for you I I I always wonder I know
you didn't make this beat but I know you
were very heavily a part of the process
of this album the [__] you mean beat was
insane yeah were you like when you first
just heard that beat that beat is so
crazy and that sample in that beat just
that had to be cuz I can only imagine
like as a producer you probably hear a
beat every once in while like [__] I
wish I made that one yeah for sure that
had to be one of those but he was kind
of like hesitant about the song really
oh yeah super hesitant like and I was
like bro this is hard like you need to
put this put this on he like you think
so I'm like yeah cuz we was locked in
and I had to go back to Atlanta for like
a week two weeks or something like that
and came back and he had it done and he
was playing me just like all the new
stuff and he played that but he was
downn there F to skip over it and I'm
like what's this he played it and I'm
like like yeah this is hard and he's
like you think so I'm like bro you you
need to put the in comparison to
everything else you need to put this out
like was crazy yeah dunk Rock that's
that's my man dunk been working for a
long time no for sure he was sitting
outside the studio in like 2019 with a
big ass sign I remember that went viral
yeah that's the guy yeah that's me
recording the video oh I remember that
yeah yeah that's that's dunk Rock like
he been grinding for a long time and
like he would come to all the events
producer events in Atlanta and in La
anywhere so I've been seeing him for a
long time so when I found out that that
was his beat I was more so happy excited
about it like yeah like oh this is this
is bro like and then when it start
taking off it's like you know I like to
see that bro like if you working and you
doing you grinding like stuff that's not
normal you're not begging and it works
for you on that type of level like I was
more so happy for him that's super fire
uh you're working on like a compilation
type project yeah yeah my album yep who
who else going to be on your album uh
nobody want to just confirm right now
you know how that [__] go you know but
it's it's definitely exciting it's
definitely something that you never
heard of and it's going to put a put a
pole inside the world of what my music
sound
like okay you know what I mean flag pole
a flag pole okay I was thinking it for
stripper pole at first n no no
you everything all
right we got to leave here and go to the
strip club uh or obviously uh the
bouncer record's doing its thing but
like what is like what's what's the plan
when you dropping more music after this
uh the bouncer or the bachelor The
Bachelor record yeah Bachelor um what's
the plan what it say one time it's been
the record's been out for like when's
the next record dropping I mean been out
for while uh we we trying to drop like
springtime okay um and really like catch
those spring going into summer months
it's going to be something you know fun
and um I'm just trying to weigh it out
right now and see what I want to use my
catalog is is at this point you probably
got like so many songs Just sitting in a
so many ain't even in the word you know
what I mean it's like so many times time
six you know what I mean but I just want
to I just want to make it make sense at
this point like these days uh timing is
everything